hey everybody time for the movie
retrospective going back to the late
1990s and doing another stephen king
adaptation i say another stephen king
adaptation because earlier this week we
talked about a return to salem's lot
which technically was not a stephen king
adaptation and that was awful but this
one
is good this is one of the good stephen
king adaptations this this sucker holds
up man
it really does it holds up i think it
it's aged well i think it's better now
than it was i mean because
they don't seem to really make movies
like this anymore it's good real good
got really good acting great story it's
a period piece they take you back to
1935 louisiana
in the prison system
it's it's real good paranormal
it's um
yeah
yeah it's aged super well
yeah definitely one of the best stephen
king adaptations and i kind of feel like
i think i saw this in the theater when
it first came out back in 1999
and i maybe saw it one more time after
that subsequently but i hadn't seen it
for like a really long time probably
like 15 20 years so i was really excited
to watch i i had forgotten that the
thing is three hours long it's three
hours long but
it doesn't seem like it to me it goes by
fast
it was kind of spellbinding i thought it
also
the movie kind of plays out the way a
good stephen king book is written so and
it's kind of rare
usually the movies and the books don't
translate well i've never read this
book
but i've read a lot of stephen king's
and this movie plays out kind of like a
stephen king book it feels like a
stephen king book
without some of the hokey dialogue
because sometimes some of his books have
internal dialogue a little bit crazy but
you do get a really good stephen king
experience with it
yeah it's really kind of like well it's
interesting because i mean obviously
this was written for screen and directed
by frank darabont who really seems to
have a good track record of adapting
stephen king things he did the mist and
obviously he did the shawshank
redemption
amazing uh like a few years before this
one which was also set in a prison
weirdly yeah but that was actually an
adaptation of a short story
this the green mile was kind of an
interesting uh experiment that stephen
king did i actually didn't read it until
a little bit later when it came out like
in one book form but when he first
published it he wanted to experiment
with publishing the way they used to
publish books back in the old days like
back in the victorian era where they'd
publish like a chapter a month or
something like that or not necessarily a
chapter but like a chunk of the book
every month so this book originally was
published as six
short books like over a six month period
that i mean they weren't that short
obviously because the final book is like
really long but he said that he wanted
to experiment with that because it used
to piss him off like people that jumped
to the end of the stories like
especially when they were reading
mysteries or something he said my mom
used to do that she used to get like a
agatha christie book and then she'd be
reading in the middle and then she'd
skip to the end and they used to drive
me crazy like she was checking to see
how it ended and he's like so i wanted
to do like an old school
only a little bit of it coming out at a
time and he's like really i didn't know
how it was gonna end either because
stephen king very famously doesn't
outline anything ahead of time he just
kind of like gets an idea and runs with
it
so so yeah so this actually came out
over a six-month period like in pieces
like in six short kind of books and then
later on i think i i honestly i don't
think i read the book until maybe after
i saw the movie because i think they put
out like a big novelization of it like
after the movie came out
but this is um a surprisingly
it's a very very faithful adaptation at
least from what i remember of the story
they really did keep and the thing too
about the
the fact that it was serialized to start
with he very specifically because he
knew that it was going to be coming out
in six like shorter six book you know
increments that each of those books was
going to be part of the larger narrative
but it was also kind of its own story as
well and the movie kind of plays out
like that too and i think that's to
i mean i think that's one of the things
that makes it so good you know what i
mean it's like it's kind of like
i don't want to say it's like six
completely different stories because
it's not it's all one big story but
there's parts of it that are like
focused on different things but they all
kind of like feed into the larger
narrative and i think it worked out
really well yeah it's it's a good book
it's about this guy who's
he's an old guy and he's in a
convalescent home
and he's going out and he's
doing something mysterious out in the
woods and he tells this woman it's in
the in the home with him his life story
about how long time ago back in the 30s
he was uh
he was a prison guard on death row in
louisiana
and he comes across this death row
inmate
who has miraculous abilities
all right
he can heal
he can heal sickness
he can even bring back the dead
and it's mind-blowing
and he's ended up on death row
and a bunch of other stuff happens
around this guy
little side missions and stuff
and it turns out that this guy
is wrongly accused he didn't do what he
was
they accused him of raping and murdering
these little girls that's not that
didn't happen he was trying to bring him
back to life yeah and the dude that
really did is on death row in there with
him
yeah he comes later played by sam
rockwell i totally forgot sam rockwell
right you guys so this prison guard is
is is like stuck within a between a rock
and a hard place
because he's he's come face to face with
one of god's miracles
all right yeah and he's being ordered to
put this to put this dude in the
electric chair and what's he gonna do he
says what am i at the end he's like what
am i going to do on judgment day when i
stand before god
and and tell him that i'd killed one of
his miracles in the electric chair
knowing that he was innocent and it was
what i'm going to tell him it was my job
so he was going to let him go wanted to
let him go and this dude is such a
innocent soul he's so good he's like he
gives up his own life
he's like no don't don't let me go
they'll ruin you behind it
and really overall when you look at the
the story the story is very christian
it's
a lot of times on the show i'll
we'll bag on christian movies because
the christians just cannot write
christian mythology it's very rare
there's a good christian movie yeah
that's true very rare uh noah i thought
was great that's jewish had christian
and then the one with the guy who was
killing the demons what was the name of
that frailty frailty that was a great
another good christian really good
christian movie where i mean at least
where the christians turned out to be
correct yeah yeah all right
very christians just can't write i don't
know what it is they just [ __ ] can't
write well believers they just like real
real strict believers you're too strict
with it yeah okay i think that's the
problem this is actually when you really
look down look into it is a retelling of
a gospel story
okay it's about a man wrongly accused
facing execution
and one of his executors becomes becomes
a believer
and then in the end is cursed with
immortality which that happens to this
guy he becomes immortal yeah well
functionally
he's not really sure how long he's going
to live now that's in christian that's
in christian mythology also where one of
the guys who caught the blood of jesus's
blood on the cross he became immortal or
was it the roman soldier that helped
that stuck the spear in him
or was it the one that carried the cross
for him on the way i think it's told a
little bit different each time but one
of those roman soldiers becomes cursed
slash blessed
with immortality and and he's gotta go
throughout the life
given his testimony as his witness
towards the sacrifice and this is the
exact same retelling of that
but it's done stephen king style in
louisiana in the 30s and it's just
really really well written
real well written it is yeah and um
it's
it's uh it
it it it addresses pretty much all the
tenets of christian um
um mythologies the more the morale the
morality tales that the mythologies um
confront you know in the gospels also
other stuff that it's outside extra
canonical stuff it's like that
it's just within
i guess you could say it's it's it's a
christian story but it's not in the
bible of course this is extra canonical
this is uh mythology but it's real good
fits right there the christian ethos
but it's not it doesn't hit you in the
gut with it it's
you have to understand christianity to
see it
it's a retelling of that
and i mean i think the great thing about
this too is that
even though i guess like the heart of
the story is you know john coffey um you
know the the guy who's kind of like the
he's just huge magical his dude yeah
he's this huge black guy his
motherfucker's jacked and he looks scary
as hell he's got to be six foot seven
probably he's six five
and he's uh just got scars all over him
and uh they think he's mentally
handicapped but he's not i don't think
he is he's just extremely
good me good tempered and and innocent
and he comes across childlike
but i don't i think his intelligence is
normal they don't know where he came
from it's like they said to us as he
just dropped out of the sky
yeah and uh
and he's
when he does talk he just talks about
the suffering of the world and how
unjust this is and how
the people killing each other it's just
a real good real good movie they never
really tell you who he is he's uh
i guess he's a gift from god yeah he's
like an enigmatic character well the
thing is they kind of i think in for
into modern paranormal parlance they
would call him an empath an empath he
does he has a lot of psychic abilities
because he can feel other people's
suffering yeah and kind of i guess he
can like feel other people's emotions i
don't know if he can necessarily like
read their thoughts now put it in you
too yeah he can do that as well she can
show you what he sees or what happened
and um he can do a lot of stuff he can
lay on hands he can resurrect the dead
yeah to a degree to a degree because i
think that well the thing that got him
in trouble
well the thing that got him in trouble
at the beginning was that like you know
he got accused of raping and killing
those two little girls but you know you
kind of find out later that he was
actually trying to bring him back but it
was too late so he kept saying it's like
i tried to take it back but it was too
late and they thought that he meant he
tried to take back killing them but he
actually tried to take it back take
death back back from him but it was too
late from them but it was too late he
didn't get he didn't get to them in time
yeah so yeah that's the thing so he can
like resurrect the dead but only like
you know within a certain time frame i
guess yeah but it damages him then he
spits out these things it looks like
flies that vanish
yeah so it's always yeah like he's
sucking the evil out and then expelling
it and i guess that's why he's got scars
all over him it leaves scars he can't
remember much either
yeah because it seems like he's yeah
he's like a figure that's almost kind of
like suffering for he's like a very like
jesus type of figure where he's just
like he's put put there to like take on
the burdens and the suffering of like
everybody on earth you know what i mean
even though if you actually go through
the gospels there are three or four
different jesus's being described
depending on the audience on the author
of who's writing the gospel but
uh he's
one of them i mean the popular
conception self-sacrificing jesus yeah
it's definitely comes across like that
yeah but what i was going to say is that
even though
his story is kind of like the heart of
the narrative i guess because this was
serialized to start with there's it
actually goes way into like a bunch of
other stories and a bunch of other
characters and i really really like that
it's almost kind of like this tapestry
of all of these other characters like in
these the death row like the other
guards and the other prisoners and like
what their deal is and
and by the way one of them just happens
to have magical powers that like
sometimes
plays into the plot but then it all kind
of like works together like you said
it's really really well written i
remember really liking the book when i
read it as well so i think all of that
was kind of there for the taking and
from what i remember like i said this is
a very very faithful adaptation i kind
of feel like they didn't really leave
all that much out but yeah like all this
stuff with like the crazy
uh the crazy prisoner like uh played by
sam rockwell who's just kind of like
totally going ape [ __ ] like all the time
they got like a whole thing with him and
then they got the whole thing with um
with the cajun guy with the mouse mr
jingles yeah they got all that then you
got like all the interior strife with
the guards and that one like little pip
squeaky [ __ ] yeah guard that's like
the [ __ ] worst um and he's been pl
he's been put like on this position
because his isn't his like aunt is this
aunt is important he's like an elected
official right she's some elected
official or is married to somebody
important or something like that and
he's kind of like a sadist and he seems
like he wants to be like
you know uh he wants to have qp he wants
to execute people because he gets off on
it
and um and he just wants to it seems
like he wants to make everyone's life as
miserable as possible like he's trying
to be important yeah real mr tough guy
so yeah so he's easily like the villain
of the piece i do kind of feel like a
lot of the other guards are just well
the other guards
are just cool and they're doing their
jobs they don't like it um you know they
get upset when they you know they kind
of get attached to the prisoners even
though something you know some of them
obviously did do bad [ __ ] like their job
is to keep them calm right and uh
they're respectful to them they say you
know they after they die they've paid
their debt you know what i mean yeah
there's all kinds of stuff you know yeah
there's no reason to make any [ __ ] like
any more miserable than it has to be
like we're already gonna kill them and
they are already being punished so
there's no reason to like make things
even worse but that one particular guard
percy wetmore is his name which is like
that's such a that's like the perfect
name i guess but yeah he's basically
like the big villain everybody else is
like pretty
is pretty okay and well obviously like
the crazy guy played by sam rockwell
he's like turns out to be a bad guy
because it turns out spoiler alert that
he's actually the person that raped and
killed those two girls that john coffey
got accused of killing yeah and then
they show the scene when they come to
coffee's uh execution
the family of the little girls are
sitting there hating on him is i feel
him hating me and it's and it's kind of
[ __ ] sucks because you're going that
would be really bad because he's
innocent he didn't do it he didn't do it
and it was the dude that did do it was
already dead
but it was the dude that the dad of the
little girls had hired to paint that
house yeah
yeah and and
and the the
the main prison guard knew who it was
but couldn't say anything yeah he
couldn't say you know he he could say it
wasn't this dude it was that dude that
you hired that you hired yeah yeah so he
they didn't even tell him i guess
because it would have made it worse on
that family i guess
well that's what they were kind of
saying like they didn't really say
anything about the family but they did
say about hal who was uh that actor
who's that actor like james cromwell is
his last name i think um the guy that
kind of played the head of the prison or
the warden or whatever and um
they said that well they're like well
now that we know that john coffey is
innocent because he's you know he's you
know took tom hanks's hand and he like
showed him what actually happened
and he's like well we know he's innocent
and
they were like well if hal can't do
anything like the word if he can't do
anything like if he can't exonerate him
if he doesn't have that power to do that
then just don't tell him because it's
like it's bad enough we all have to live
with this guilt we don't want to like
more people have to live with it too and
like i said he has like a big discussion
with john coffey like you know what do
you want me to do you want me to leave
the door open i'll let you out he's like
i know you didn't do it didn't just
catch him again anyway that's what he
figured and honestly he said it's okay
he's like you know because like i said
because he was an empath he was just
kind of like i'm tired like his whole
entire life all he feels is like the
suffering and pain of other people and
he said he even says like it's like
shards of glass in my brain or something
like that and so he just doesn't want to
feel that anymore and he's just kind of
tired of the world being the way it is
so he just wants to check out jay
referred to it as magic it's not magic
it's
psychic abilities
slash
spiritual abilities which is one of the
same thing if you ask me but it's not
magic
it's
he's an empath
he uh has the ability to uh make you see
what he feels if he touches you
he can lay hands on some person and heal
him
he can resurrect the dead to a limited
amount
and he also can um
feel
he can feel people's pain from a long
ways away too
remember he could he could feel what
yeah because yeah because when uh when
delacroix got executed
yeah holy [ __ ] that was one of the most
horrifying [ __ ] scenes ever right oh
my god because it's like you don't i
don't think they even do they ever say
like what delaquan did like to get on
death row i don't think they ever say
they said what the other guy did either
the indian guy
oh yeah that's right the guy played by
graham green they just want you to judge
him for how they are not what they did
not what they did yeah so yeah so you're
just seeing delaqua like you know
however long he's been on death row and
you're just seeing him as kind of like
this daughtering like nice little old
cajun man who's you know who has this
little mouse who's all he's always
playing with and everything and you know
he's going to die and like i said all
the guards are really attached to him
and stuff and they never really tell you
like what he did like it's impossible
some kind of homosexual murderer or
something because that one guard kept
just you know
slandering him as being gay
yeah either that or like that either
that or that was just like something
because he knew that would like piss him
off i don't really know but yeah so it
could have been that but and like i said
homosexual when they bring him in to you
know get killed and everything like that
it's like
[ __ ] that's like really upsetting too
because he just seemed like such a cool
character
and you could like all into math i'll
train in the mouse and everything and
like all the guards are like really
upset and then the whole [ __ ] happens
with that stupid little [ __ ] nut um like
that percy guy saying oh i want to be in
the front and the execution and he was
mad at delaqua because um you know they
call him dell for short
because um
dell had kind of like well hadn't hadn't
like um the crazy guy like grabbed percy
like sam rockwell's character and then
like that he wet his pants and dell was
like making fun of him about it yeah so
he just was trying to get back at him
and plus he was you know he stomped on
his mouse at some point too but yeah
which that really upset me but
but the guy but uh john coffey brings
the mouse back he brings it back and it
was and it's still alive yeah in the
modern day like he's still got the mouse
yeah it became immortal too because i'm
sitting there going [ __ ] man how long
because that's what the old guy was
saying at the end like old you know old
tom hanks character is just kind of like
well if the mouse is still alive and
that was like in 1935 and what mice live
what like two years or maybe years and
it's still alive like in presumably in
1999 or whatever the hell year it was
supposed to be right and he's like well
[ __ ] man i'm 108 now like how long am i
going to live like he might live forever
it was a retelling of that eternal roman
soldier that's what it is
yeah but it was that i mean so that the
whole scene where uh you know where
percy like is just like getting back at
dell he's like i'm not even gonna wet
the sponge on the electric chair so
he'll just sit there and cook and like
he'll still be alive and it was like
[ __ ] horrifying and then it was so
horrifying that because i'm sitting
there looking at percy go what the [ __ ]
did you think was gonna happen you
little twerp you know what i mean cause
it's like he looks at it at first like
yeah fry [ __ ] and then like he's
just like oh my god this is like way
worse and then he turned away and then
tom hanks is like you look at it like
you're the one that did that you know
what i mean so it was even like too much
for him and then they make him clean it
up and everything so i really liked when
that guy got like [ __ ] punched and
they were all just kind of like coffee
punished him though he brought justice
to him he did yeah that's like that was
probably like the best way to go about
that because like we said it was kind of
like killing two birds with one stone i
don't want to spoil that in case you
guys haven't seen it though yeah i mean
i kind of feel like a lot of people have
seen this because you know it came out a
long time ago and a lot of people have
read the book as well but yeah this is
definitely one of the best stephen king
adaptations i don't think it's quite as
revered as shawshank redemption but
when this came out it was nominated for
four oscars
so including best picture it didn't win
but it was nominated it's top notch
movie it really is it's definitely one
of the best uh adaptations and i was
gonna say too i was gonna say about poor
uh michael clark duncan who played john
coffey
he was actually um he actually started
out as like not surprisingly because
he's [ __ ] gigantic but um he started
out as like a bodyguard yeah uh any a
club bouncer and stuff i think he worked
for the notor for notorious bag
and uh when that guy got shot when
notorious bijo got shot um he's like
yeah i don't want to really do this
anymore so he was in acting so i think
he was in i feel like he was in some
action movies what he did conair i think
he was maybe in conair
and he's been like with nicholas cage
and he's been in some other movies but
this was his first big role and i think
oh he was in armageddon
and bruce willis who was also an
armageddon like when he heard about this
movie he said you have to put this guy
in the movie even though he'd only been
like in a couple movies like in small
roles he does a great job and he's he
does a great job amazing in this he's so
so he's gonna cry on
yeah it's like honestly like i remember
like i said i saw in the theater i was
like god that was [ __ ] one of the
saddest [ __ ] movies i've ever seen
it's terribly terribly sad it's like
it's not only sad when like dell gets it
because that's [ __ ] up but then like
you know when john coffey gets executed
at the end too it's just like oh my god
it's awful and like all the other guards
are like standing there crying and [ __ ]
like that it's terrible it's like so you
know have the have the tissues handy
like when you're watching this one but
you know what i was gonna say is that
the people that were up for that role
first which i just don't think this
would have worked at all uh ving rhames
who maybe could have pulled it off i
love ving rhames but um not big enough
well
well um the thing about it is john
coffey in the book he was seven feet
tall yeah um in the movie he's really
only six foot five but they huge well
they did a lot of he's not actually as
big yeah he's not actually as big as
they show them in the movie um
it is big but the thing about it is that
some of the other actors like cromwell
and stuff like that were almost as tall
as that so they had to like shoot him
differently at different angles and
stuff like that to make him look like
way way bigger and i think they also
like made the you know the bed and his
prison cell they made that like smaller
than an actual bed and the uh electric
chair they made that smaller than an
actual election it's just to make him
look like he was big giant because
that's in the book like i said he's this
big seven foot tall but yeah they so
they said ving rhames or you're gonna
laugh shaquille o'neal yeah which uh
doesn't have enough mass well shaquille
o'neal is pretty big i'm just talking
about like not even from the physicality
standpoint because they can shoot around
that shaquille o'neal
would not have been able to do this role
no this dudes this dude's biceps are the
size of bowling balls
okay
he's got huge [ __ ] biceps he's huge
but i no but what i was saying that is
that even if
you know they
you know they had a big guy that could
do it but shaquille o'neal is not
an actor he's not like a great actor and
this role
there's a lot of like real emotionally
wrenching
kind of [ __ ] that you had to do for this
role and i just cannot see shaquille
o'neal pulling that off no so i'm really
really glad well not only just the
acting it's just
the the the intimidation factor how big
this dude is what's his name
michael clark duncan mike michael he's
uh he's huge he passed away sadly in
2012 he had a heart attack only 54 years
old his
his well [ __ ] he weighed a lot
yeah the human heart can only do so much
yeah uh look that's not natural okay
that's that's anabolics
and when you're have a frame that big
and you pile that much muscle onto it
that's a lot of stress on your heart
little dudes like me can get away with
it because it's not as much meat you
know to power our hearts are all about
the same size
but uh no he he's impressive
super impressive literally his arm his
biceps are the size of bowling balls
and
it's a huge frame it's [ __ ] lats and
everything
you know i'm into that [ __ ] i can
[ __ ] judge how about he's huge
that dude's very strong
but i think that that was what was so
cool and i think that that's about his
character and i think that's something
that stephen king had in mind when he
was writing the character as you wanted
to be like a gentle giant type of thing
where he looked super scary and super
intimidating but he was just like the
sweetest gentlest
kindest person ever he's a god-like soul
yeah almost angelic and that's what
they're trying to they're trying to
protect basically he's an angel
yeah and he he killed it i mean he was
great in this he was great in this yeah
for like i said for having only been in
like a few minor
you know parts up to then um so thanks
to bruce willis for recommending him for
this movie because he was he [ __ ]
spot on he killed it um and the funny
thing too is that tom hanks i think was
not actually the original choice for
this i think it was john travolta was
who they asked which again
i don't think that would happen i'm not
a big fan of tom hanks but he's [ __ ]
awesome in this awesome he's per he's
actually perfectly cast this is one of
his best roles he's perfectly casting
castaway is good too but uh this is his
best role if you ask me
yeah i mean because the thing about it
is that i think that
you really really likeable yeah you
really needed somebody and like all the
characters that played guards other than
the one [ __ ] one who was supposed to
be an [ __ ] i think they got really
good actors for all of these because
you know you're inclined to maybe not be
as charitable toward these characters
because it's like you know they work on
death row and blah blah but the fact
that they made them all just nice guys
like regular guys all the guards were
cool including their boss he was cool
too yeah that's right it was just that
one little [ __ ] yeah that was that one
little [ __ ] and it's just like every
time and i know this is terrible and i
know the movie's like manipulating my
emotions and stuff but
every single time like that dude got
punched or they put him in the in the
straight jacket and threw him in the
thing i was like yeah [ __ ] that dude
that's like god damn it that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it's just like i
liked when they had because the thing
about it is that even though you know
tom hanks everybody like all the other
guards they were all really really
likable characters but even the most
saintly person if you had to put up with
that little [ __ ] face all the time like
every single day of your life
um yeah you'd probably you'd want to
beat the [ __ ] out of them too and i
don't think anybody would blame you like
acting the way that you know that they
handled it the right way i think they
handled it exactly right yeah like yeah
they smacked him around and stuff like
that but he needed it that dude should
not have been a guard no he should not
at all he should have been an inmate
that's what kind that's and that's yeah
because that dude was [ __ ] he's a
maniac
and and that's eventually what happens
to him he becomes an inmate
at a mental hospital yeah the one that
he was supposed to go and like work at
as like a cushy new job he just wanted
to see an execution first because he was
a [ __ ] sadist yeah but well among a
lot among a lot of other things he was
just
he was he was uh
trying to be as important as he could
and trying to be as big and bad as he
could but he was a weaselly literally
yeah he was a
little [ __ ] and he he only attacked
basically the helpless which are these
inmates yeah these inmates are helpless
yeah and then
the inmates that were a threat he was
terrified of him yep he only he only
would pick on inmates that were helpless
yep so that's the lowest of the low yeah
so yeah he really needed this [ __ ]
inmates that were bad asses oh no he was
scared of them oh he he couldn't even
attack an inmate who was a a badass
inmate who was attacking one of his
buddies yeah another another guard he
didn't step forward and yeah he just
stood there like
there's just so little a man in him you
know he couldn't even save one of his
partners
he was too scared yeah so like he said
he was always picking on people like
weaker than him like and like i said
stepping on that mouse and stuff like i
mean just for that yep you should get
your ass kicked i'm just saying but uh
but yeah so honestly if you haven't seen
the green mile in a while um i would
really suggest like revisiting it
because i forgot i remember it being
really good and i remember really liking
it like when i saw in the theater and
then went again but watching it again
i it was just i was like man i forgot
how [ __ ] good this movie is it's so
good and it's like like i said it's very
very long we watch it on hbo max i'm
sure it's somewhere else it's really
long it's three hours but it totally did
not seem it i was just like mesmerized
the whole time i got so into all the
characters all the acting is just
impeccable and it's just
i mean it's sad and it's like but
there's kind of funny stuff and it's
like it's really touching and
heartbreaking it's just i don't know
it's great i just really really liked it
i enjoyed it a lot like
i think this time more than maybe even
more than the first time
it's just aged real well in a world of
[ __ ] shitty movies this one's kind of
[ __ ] just remained a strong movie
i mean like i said frank darabont he's
kind of the man he's really kind of made
some of the best stephen king
adaptations and honestly the best
stephen king adaptations that were oh my
god uh the best stephen king adaptations
that were kind of more
drama you know what i mean because like
i said he made shawshank redemption
which easily one of the best movies of
the 90s yeah i haven't seen it a long
time i remember that one being good too
oh my god that one was amazing um but
this one is like right up there with it
and it's like you know i i don't know if
anything can be as good as shawshank
redemption because shawshank redemption
was just like the [ __ ] best but this
one is like pretty this is almost as
good i kind of feel it i really was into
the paranormal aspect of this
i was as well and and like i said and i
liked that
it had that going on but there was so
much other stuff going on too so it
wasn't it wasn't just focused on that
one thing it was almost kind of like
this whole tapestry of this interrelated
like oh there's other characters yeah
there's a whole mosaic of morality tales
going on yeah
and um like i said they're all
they're all basically from the christian
ethos but it that transfers into other
religions and philosophies too they're
just kind of universal really the best
stuff that's in christian ethio ethos is
just universal this is universal stuff
yeah you know
a lot of things that are in there have
more to do with some of the crazy [ __ ]
that's in the bible has more to do with
religious purity you know ritual purity
yeah which doesn't really apply anything
to modern life don't anyway damn arc
like a boom oh yes
[Laughter]
there's no real morality tale behind
that just don't do it don't disobey it
even if that shit's fallen don't catch
it
[Laughter]
god's a hard ass
yeah but that doesn't really teach much
today you know uh
but no it's just a good it's a good uh
good story and um
uh for
christians or non-christians alike would
like this it's just a universal
yeah it's just like a really good just
kind of like
good versus i don't want to say like
simplistic it's not that but it's like a
pretty clear like these are good people
and this is what happens and then this
guy's like clearly a bad person and
right you know what i mean but it kind
of addresses how
you know bad [ __ ] happens to good people
like all the time too because john cox
had mercy on bad people yeah that too
that too which i kind of liked that yeah
because sometimes the so-called good
people are the bad people and yeah
sometimes the the so-called bad people
are the good people like coffee was a
bad guy from the point of view of
society but it was a lie he wasn't bad
he was an angel yeah
he was just very interesting right yeah
and people were just like [ __ ] to him
yeah so it's that kind that kind of
stuff yeah
but yeah this is uh a great movie easily
one of the best stephen king adaptations
and if you haven't seen it in a while
you should definitely go give it another
look like i said it's on hbo max maybe
other places as well uh so yeah if
you've seen it lately or if you've seen
it a long time ago and remember it like
tell us about it in the comments and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys again
on the next one bye